we do have major breaking news right now
explosions now heard and kev as and here
with the latest is our own trey yingst
he is live uh i guess just in the last
couple of minutes you heard the first
explosions of the night is that correct
sean that's correct right now the
ukrainian capital kiev is under attack
there are russian strikes taking place
right now we heard two large explosions
pretty close to the downtown part of the
ukrainian capital and then a smaller
explosion a little bit further out these
are the first strikes to take place
tonight and it was a night that people
were anticipating
in the region could escalate even
further as those russian troops get
closer and closer to the ukrainian
capital reports right now indicate that
from the north east there are russian
troops heading down a major highway
toward the capital of kiev this is
significant because we talked about
earlier today in chernobyl north of the
city the ability of russian troops to
move
on a a key road after defeating
ukrainian forces so already it is
shaping up to be a multi-pronged attack
on the ukrainian capital and these
airstrikes part of what we understand
would be a larger campaign if the
russians continue to move forward with
this assault on the city what we can
expect in the coming days
likely a deterioration of the situation
the ukrainian forces say they are
successful in many ways when it comes to
using things like anti-tank missiles
they have not been as successful in
using any sort of air defense and we
have not even seen any air defense going
off around the ukrainian capital but it
was significant today that they were
able to take back that airport about 40
minutes away from where we are right now
just outside of the capitol russian
forces attacked this airfield with
multiple attack helicopters the
ukrainians launching a counter-offensive
and able to take it back but this can
only go on for so long there's a limited
amount of military supplies and forces
and as we know according to ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky at least 137
people were killed today in less than 24
hours following this russian invasion
into the country and again as we can
report right now the ukrainian capital
is receiving some sort of strikes
tonight we're not sure if they are crews
or ballistic missiles both have been
used since this conflict erupted
yesterday sean all right trey thank you
great reporting hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else